what only fans form a coin
fair enough and the the only the only
fans like i said earlier on the only
fans generation i don't know what's
going to happen to them after this
this bubble bursts they're going to be
wow homeless
they're not going to be homeless they'll
be fine women are the women are the
fastest growing population of homeless
sorry the only fans
women will not be homeless because i
think they'll have fans
that will literally simp for them and
take them in
women would rather
women would rather be homeless women
women would rather be homeless than mary
a beta you haven't learned that from
this show
i lay out these numbers for girls all
the time yeah i don't they
they would rather be homeless than be
with a beta wait let's ask the panel i
think there'll always be space for it
yeah i think because there will always
be no not only fans the women after
doing honesty yeah after they did
because it's got a timeline hasn't it
yeah i don't know does it will it just
evolve into something it might evolve
but i'm just saying like women are
capitalizing on this only fans thing
right now because it's like hot right
it's like i can walk around in my shoes
and you know get guys to you know don't
donate but how long i cause i think that
the guys that are subscribed to only
fans
are
i'm not trying to disrespect guys but
it's like a
it's like you were saying it's a form of
escapism
it's being able to fulfill a fantasy
for a certain amount of time
but i think a lot of men tend to get
upset at the fact
that
just be honest those women in real life
are not going to pay those guys any
attention but i think it will do you
know what i mean like into like the ai
stuff you know when you can put headsets
on and women
so it's almost like you're physically
feeling them yeah
oh and the there
yeah that's what i was about to say
they're making the robot people start
selling their robots that's all they've
been making they've been making they've
been selling them the latex
um
yeah the girls will just start making
molds of their uh
yeah you could buy the mold of you your
woman that you like
and then well i think you can even
there's like sex dolls aren't there yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but i think i think it makes men's
expectations very unrealistic because
that's what i said like for your if you
get into a relationship after that and
you're addicted to that what is going to
be your
psychology in your relationship
like after being addicted to that
i would say it's the same for um
women with is it pair bonding is that
the right word yeah it's very bonding
yeah i would say that's the
same for women how men um think that
the main guy
has or the the guy who alpha whittled
her
and they constantly are thinking they
think that they constantly are thinking
about that top guy i would say it's the
same
that's for me that's how i would think
it would be for men when it comes to
corn that they're always thinking about
these different scenarios to where
they're not even trying to connect with
the person that's in front of them
so then is it real life like
if you can watch corn
do people try to transfer what happens
in corn into their real life and is it
viable
in the chat i i think you can transfer
it um into your life if you if you're in
that 20 or you earn a certain amount you
know you hear about girls going to dubai
with these old arab men if you've got
money money talks but the difference
between
men and women is women don't tend to
take date backwards men will date
anything women do women date upwards
they want to because they want that
alpha they want that man that can kind
of say
yeah they want to secure it pawn
transfers either
corn transfers either way
regardless of whether you do 20 or not
because
because everybody's watching it and no
i'm talking about actually making it
into a physical reality yeah that's what
i'm saying so so
so for example when i started having sex
deep throats weren't a thing it was
oh anal wasn't a thing
but through the consumption of corn
and
men watching it and trying it on
whoever that then seeing having sex with
a dating
most women i would come across now it's
a giving that is you're going to have to
be a deep throat champion i'm talking
about the level of woman though
yeah no
no
so do you
so
think about the champion
[Laughter]
yeah you think you could
as you are now you don't know how your
circumstance is yeah yeah you think you
could get her to judge you a hundred
percent
um
you mean if i if i walk into my
celebrity crush now yeah and we both
have the same stayers no no she's got
her status so who's yours no mommy we
both have to say i have my status now
and she has her and she's just leslie as
yeah oh no of course not she's as i'm
saying so that's why i was saying
finances play a big part in it because
you could get these guys that are
subscribing to only fans yeah more time
they've usually got some cash they've
usually like yeah they could make that a
reality this is what happens that's why
i use the example of dubai and stuff
like this you get like a four out of ten
man that will say to his cornhub crush
and he'll find her on instagram and say
i'll give you 20 grand oh that's what
you mean you know what i thought you
meant i thought you meant that actions
yeah transferring into jesus christ yeah
but i'm talking about that too i'm
talking about the actions that you see
within the corn movies yeah are you
trying to transfer that yeah yeah yeah
yeah because like i said back in the day
there was no such thing as anal deep
throats not just deep choking whilst
deep throat and slobber on on the
none of those things were the norm but
now that is the norm
to 90 of women i come across
and that's because of corn because
before men weren't one in that
men were just one in regular
just wanting sex we have a lot to learn
violence
that's what i'm saying why do men want
that
men
it's because of corn that yeah because
even myself so you know when i said
start in the the
descent
yeah right
top shelf yeah page three
oh so you're desensitized to normal sex
so yeah it's not it's not even that you
just i don't even it's not it's not
about being desensitized to normal sex
it's just seeing new things and being
like oh that looks cool
do you know it's just uh you just you've
seen and you're like that looks that's
what i said you don't know how you feel
it more so i'm not even that's what
you're even about nothing ever satisfied
that's what i mean that's what i'm
getting at i don't think it's that no it
is because us as humans we we're
set up or hardwired to always want to be
on an uphill climb we always want to we
never want to become stagnant so yeah
that's what i said earlier on in
conversation
when you get complacent with something
or something becomes normal yeah you
want the next thing and the next thing
is usually something you shouldn't do
yeah but you're like it's exciting so
it's turning me on so is abusing women
exciting for men where did that come
from yeah so
so go ahead with that wait what did you
wait what did you just say where's the
beauty
that's not considered
that's not considered abuse because of
what he said when it comes to corn how
that has become something that's in it
and i would say within
society as well they may not be saying
hey go look at this corn video and watch
this they'll say it in their lyrics
they'll say what they're talking about
like oh choke me out oh touch the little
dangly thing in the back of my throat
and they all can great so the female can
be hearing that and the guy may be
viewing it and then they're like oh i
want that and he's like oh bet i saw
that i want to try that and it's just
it's not something that they would
consider abuse because they they
essentially
like it they want it i'm not talking i'm
not talking about in the bedroom like in
real life i'm more speaking about
in porn so we've got
i was so good before so we've gone from
like you know maybe some bare boobs out
once upon a time or a shoulder or an
ankle that was like oh my gosh
now we're now we're at choking but
that's not consistent
yeah well having your hair pulled
underneath something in your beard so
something in your mouth something in
your bum something from underneath
there's an account
and then getting beaten as well so so
the thing is like this is so bad but
women like abuse something yeah
we do because there's there's reddit
threads of women talking about how they
like the handmaid's tale
and they're attracted to the grape
scenes in it
there's reddit threads the what the what
scenes the group have do you know what
the handmaid's tale is the grapes the
grapes
and the handmaid's tales
there's women that make reddit threads
about how they're attracted to it
on top of that only women experience
stockholm syndrome most of the time
in general because which is you know
what stockholm syndrome is
so so women fall in love with their
captor they're captains yeah men don't
like
yeah it's a weird it's because it's
because biologically where we nurture
our relationship so whether that
relationship is healthy or not we're
still going to nurture it it ties in
with domestic violence
no it's the dark triad traits like the
the the here the traits that the hero
has the villain does too
so we want a man that can protect us but
how does he protect us by beating up
someone else
so if he beats our ass we know he can
beat up someone else
that aggression that's in him we're
attracted to it yeah but it's like a
double-edged sword yeah
like like jess said it's not it's not
it's not considered abuse it's
i mean i've had women want me to punch
them slap them put
naturally it's not something i want to
do to a woman but most of the things
i've done that's physical
has been requested by a woman
i do i mean i've heard that so many
times from guys where they're like a
girl asks them to do something
and they're like and they're like are
you are you sure like please don't make
me do no and that's what i was saying
when it comes to society it's so like
in the culture to have that stuff done
to you that if you're in a group of your
home girls and she's like yeah i got
choked out last night and she's like oh
yeah i got slapped across the face and
you're like well i'm not doing that i
want to be able to fit in with my friend
yeah but just because it's normalized
doesn't mean it's okay yeah but we know
that we know that as humans but we still
in some
way or fashion we go along with the
culture whatever it may be and you train
your brain to like it mm-hmm you are
literally your brain well this year they
had a film on netflix called 365 days
did you see that yeah
that woman was kidnapped and forced to
love this man and the big
consumers of this film were women they
loved it yeah and it was literally the
most quote-unquote toxic masculine yeah
movie that you could ever think about
and women that's even like fantasy
yeah
but then like you said it's not abuse
then if you'd like it yeah it's
definitely that's what i'm saying is
it's really not
i think like
i think i think part of it is and i'm i
can't speak on women's behalf you'll
correct me if i'm wrong but women like
to be dominated or put in their place
yeah yeah they want a man that can
put them in that place
they want a man they can put them in
their place but the right way without
putting his hands on them but he can
talk to you to make you think like oh
that kind of put me on the back make
love to my mind
no that's true that's true no girl wants
a guy that we can walk all over
like i always hear guys complain about
being like the nice guy but you're not
nice if you don't know how to stand up
for your health yourself you're just
scared yeah you're and we can sense that
when we don't
we don't want to date a guy that's more
of a see than we are you know
it's very true yeah it's just knowing
the right way to do it isn't it that's
part of it like and in your relationship
that's what you figure out what what
your kind of boundaries are
and that is why i guess toxic
relationships are the thing nowadays
right yeah because people want to be
like
they want some kind of excitement
abuse do you know do you know what i
think it is i think it's women can't get
the guys like the women aren't they're
they're less pure than they've ever been
mm-hmm and they're in worse shape than
we've ever been
so they and there's a smaller and
smaller percentage of men that women
want and they can't get them so they'll
settle for the guy that's maybe abusive
or toxic or whatever because they can't
get the guy that they want
you think that's it
yeah because he has the dark triad
traits he like no girl is going to go
for a guy with nothing never yeah like
you might you might think he has nothing
but usually the guy the guys that girls
tell me had nothing he's usually tall
he's usually good looking maybe he's a
bum but he has the tall good looking
and and he knows how to have six
yes they're always the best apparently
sorry say that again
they're always the best in bed
apparently
it's a secret apparently
apparently apparently no
i wouldn't
we don't believe you